uh good afternoon everybody uh or I
should say good morning to those of you
um that are in time zones that are still
morning um I'm Elaine lion I'm an
associate professor at the University of
Utah and um a medical director at AUP
Laboratories and I'm welcoming you to
this Web Conference I wanted to remind
people that they can submit questions
anytime during the presentation I may
not be able to get to them right then um
I will try to monitor it some in case I
can answer a quick question at that
point uh but if not I'll I will answer
them um towards the end so please submit
your
questions I will be talking today about
pharmacogenomics Next Generation
sequencing and clinical
interpretation I work in a clinical Clea
Reference Laboratory and uh we have been
working on Next Generation sequencing
and have several Next Generation
sequencing assays available but we don't
have pharmacogenomics assays available
yet by Next Gen um so what I'm
presenting on today is kind of a proof
of concept or a proof of principle and
the work that we're doing to evaluate
whether we can use the U Next Generation
sequencing for our
pharmacogenomics the disclaimer I will
have on this is that this data is very
complex and so this is a very early um
step into it we have a lot more work to
do before it really becomes a clinical
test but I wanted to um show a couple of
approaches that we've looked into that
may be suitable for The Clinical
Laboratory I do have a disclosure I'm on
an Advisory Board although there's not a
a direct conflict of interest with what
I'm presenting
today so um
I wanted to talk today I'll give
somewhat of a background of the
pharmacogenetics and some and then go
into the some of the targets we'll be
looking at I'll then go into next
Generation sequencing and exom data as
well as Gene panel data and throughout
the time I am going to focus on
interpretation and some of the
challenges that we have with
pharmacogenetics that are even above
normal challenges of Next Generation
sequencing so so I'll start with the
definitions and you hear a lot of the
terms personalized medicine or
pharmacogenetics pharmacogenomics and I
think those two are being used
interchangeably although
pharmacogenetics should refer to a gene
whereas pharmacogenomics should refer to
multiple genes or the genome um and then
companion diagnostic so personalized Med
medicine is a systematic use of
information about an individual to
select or optimize um preventative or
therapeutic care pharmacogenetics then
examines the impact of genetic variation
on the response to medications so this
is to tailor drug therapy um at a dosage
that is most appropriate for the
individual patient so sometimes
personalized medicine and
pharmacogenetics um are used somewhat
interchangeably and then companion
Diagnostics is is a portion of
pharmacogenetics and these are assays
that are
um used for a specific therapy um to
stratify the disease status or select
the proper medication so it also it's a
a bit more of a of a
specialty section of pharmacogenetics or
personalized medicine and I will be
using talking about a little bit of of
some of these
today so there has been a lot of talk
about personalized medicine or companion
diagnosis ICS and the promise that this
has um and so when we talk about
companion Diagnostics per se that's
usually a single
assay uh and it's done with a specific
therapeutic product so the concept is to
identify patients most likely to benefit
from a therapy or those likely not to
respond or those likely to have an
adverse
reaction these types of tests are
considered high risk by the FDA and the
reason is that if you give wrong result
it could lead to withholding appropriate
therapy or administering inappropriate
therapy so there has been some criticism
that the genomic medicine hasn't
realized the promise for personalized
medicine and it's true we still have a
long ways to go in understanding The
genome but there are some success
stories and in some ways that we are
using um and that we have realized um
some of the opportunities of
personalized
medicine in the oncology field uh
looking at somatic mutations um there
has been advances in tumor biology
understanding the tumor biology
understanding the expression of genes
and then also understand mutations that
may um
then make you resist for a certain
treatment Etc in inh herited or germine
variation we talk mainly about enzymes
and so um the cyoc promy for 50s the
ugts but we also have to realize that
there are also receptors that are very
much
involved and in an emerging field is uh
looking at Host factors that predict
treatment for infectious disease now
that's different than infectious
diseases where you're looking at the
viral genomes and resistance mutation
and I noticed a mistake in these slides
just last night the il28b and the HLA
571 are examples of the host factors
predict predicted for treatment
infectious diseases so those two need to
be um put up in the previous um bullet
but the laboratory Community has
embraced in areas that do have clinical
utility at the moment uh some of the
personalized medicine and
pharmacogenetic
testing now I will be focusing on
inherited or germine um variation today
so mainly the the enzymes um and that
are involved with drug
metabolism so when we talk about drug
therapy we talk about phaco kinetics or
in other words what the body does to the
drug which are the metabolizing enzymes
but please also keep in mind that
there's the phod Dynamics meaning what
the drug does to the body the response
um the mechanisms and actions for these
drugs now um the pharmacokinetics when
they looked at a dose response and a a
the dose required for a desirable
response in the little chart at the
bottom of the slide uh it was noticed
that they were grouping into
approximately three different groups and
this actually then
um could be related to the drug
clearance and actually has been shown to
um to be associated with genotypes of
specific um genes so for example if you
have a porn
metabolizer or a slow metabolizer you
will have non-functional genes or a fast
metabolizer and the genotypes on the top
show you the different types of
genotypes so a slow metabolizer would
have both of the person's genes um
knocked out or basically non functional
whereas an intermediate metabolizer
would have only one of the genes um
nonfunctional uh a regular normal two
functional genes but then you have a
fast metabolizer that could actually
have duplication of
genes and this is for my pharmacogenetic
I'm sorry my pharmacology friends to
just point out that it's not all about
DNA so genes are important but in in the
pharmacology field the formulation the
body mass the age uh concurrent
medications and even diet all affect how
um how drugs work for an
individual and also for my pharmacology
friends that there are limitations to
the pharmacogenetics tests and I think
this is one of the take home messages
that I'd like you to have so first of
all genot type does it always equal
phenotype um it makes the interpretation
of results difficult if that's not
always the case it also makes the
clinical application of the data
difficult one of the reasons for this is
that the pathways may be necessary to
understand and looking for different
variants in different genes of the
pathway so if one gene um product is not
being produced
it could be uh another pathway is
available and could use that so we do
need to start thinking in Pathways and
not simply individual
genes so the content of our
pharmacogenetic tests varies among
Laboratories even for the ones that are
existing so one reason is that there are
licensing issues uh that are still in
play um even though there was a Supreme
Court decision uh about DNA as a
naturally occurring um substance there
are still a lot of questions about the
licensing then the question is there are
clinically significant single nucleotide
variants but then there's an awfully lot
of variants that are not well
characterized they may be called
polymorphisms um but we really don't
know what they do so we still are
struggling um with
understanding which are the clinically
significant variant
uh Gene dose is very important as I
showed before you could have
duplications of genes you can also have
deletions of genes and in many cases or
in some cases the the AL are described
by the num an combination of variants on
the hype and right now all of the
genetic tests that's being done is
genotyping we are not doing molecular
haplotyping so we need to
infer the hpot types and we do that
based on known um linkage between the
variants
now one of the challenges of
pharmacogenetics is that molecular
testing isn't necessarily a um very
quick test to
do it's not quite as simple and isn't
typically done in stat labs or in a stat
time so for example with us in a
Reference Laboratory
um it would take a day for the sample to
get to us uh through our system we need
to then extract the DNA from the sample
um run the test and it and some of the
tests may take several hours when you
talk into next Generation sequencing
tests actual running the test takes days
so this is not going to be a quick turn
around time and yet in many cases that's
exactly what is needed if somebody comes
into the doctor they need to get started
on on a medication um quickly there
isn't a time to do the workup before
they may need to to try the
medication and then the big question is
the far
pharmacoeconomics can we using our
pharmacogenetic tests be able to really
make an impact on the patient care and
the costs of Health
Care okay so now that I've given you all
of the limitations for pharmacogenetics
tests I want to go into um a little bit
of the background of uh some of the
terminology so we classify them in
different categories so an extensive or
is metabolizer is actually the normal
metabolizer a Poe metabolizer means that
you have
no um functional
protein on the other hand an
intermediate means you have some
functional protein you have some enzyme
activity but not the normal number and
then obviously the ultra rapid
metabolizer which would be the multiple
copies of functional genes are the
variant and Regulatory regions that
increases the
expression now as I said this is we put
them into categories but please realize
that this is more of a Continuum we
don't exactly know an intermediate
metabolizer may actually be 50% of
normal but it may go down to the 20% of
normal or even below so uh I I also like
to think of it this as a Continuum and
not simply for discrete
categories now to make matters more
complex is that in the enzymes are often
considered recessive patterns I'm not
going to say it's a recessive disease
because none of these cause diseases um
you don't even know about them until you
are challenged with an EXO ogous
substance such as a drug but it does
show a recessive pattern in some
ways that to be a poor metabolizer you
have to have two copies one on each Al
um of non-functional ones so this slide
simply shows the different combinations
two functional alyss will be extensive a
functional and a decreased function will
still be considered an extensive
metabolizer a functional and a
nonfunctional
um a little combination will give you an
intermediate or some people still also
call that an extensive
metabolizer so there's some discrepancy
between um what different Laboratories
May call the functional non-functional
um
genotype a decrease in non-functional
alyss would be then intermediate two
non-functional alyss would be poor a
duplication um and then functionals on
both will be Ultra fast but there's also
known duplications of non-functional
oils so it is important to know if the
duplication is a functional or a
non-functional
Al um so how are the data used to select
or avoid the drugs and we need to also
think in two different um ways so one is
that some drugs are inactivated by the
uh pharmacogenetic Gene product so if
they are poor
metabolizer with a drug that's
inactivated with it you want to avoid
the drug or use lower
doses the intermediate metabolizers Also
may require low lower doses doses but
the intermediate categories have been
less studied and there's simply less
good data for
that the ultr metabolizers may require a
higher dose or they may not respond at
all to the drug and you may want to
avoid it there are some dos guidelines
that are published and again this does
not replace the need for therapeutic
drug monitoring or other clinical
monitoring now on the other hand drugs
may be activated by a a pharmacogenetic
gene so it may be a pro drug that only
then becomes activated with a a
metabolism so in this case if you're a
poor
metabolizer then again you may want to
avoid the drug or give a higher dose
the um intermediates may require higher
doses the ultra fast metabolizers may
require lower
doses
so when Laboratories try to do an
interpretation it really depends on the
drug that they're given and whether it's
a prod drug that's activated by the the
um the gene product or if it's a drug
that's
inactivated so
I'm the common um genes that that we
look at and then uh go into these genes
and others with the um exome and and
genome
sequencing so cytochrome p450 2d6 is a
very is a um enzyme that is responsible
for the metabolism of nearly a quarter
of all drugs and it's also commonly inv
involved with drug rug interactions um
the genotypes are given star Al little
numbers and so um this is a challenge
with our standard nomenclature and
molecular genetics and as I commented
before that the haplotypes the
combination of Varon one Aly um may be
how these alyss are described the
phenotypes um 60% are extensive
metabolizers uh and about but about 10%
of the people are poor metabolizers
and then others intermediate or Ultra
fast here are some some of the common
sus and I'm showing this to you so you
can see the number of nucleotides so for
example the first one is star 2 and
there be two a b or d there are some
minor variations between those in um
what what variants are on the a um but
2A has the minus 1584 G that's a
promoter variant um that can affect the
expression of the gene the other three
are fairly common um variants a star
three is a delation of an a a star four
you can see
has 100 plus um 1661 is a common variant
1846 is what we would call um the a
defining variant
that's the mutation that causes it to be
nonfunctional in this case it's a spite
um
variant star five is the entire Gene
that's deleted um and then I wanted to
skip down a little bit to Star 10 so if
you look at star 10 it has the 100 C to
T and then two common um um
variants if you get a 100 c t and an
1846 those are assumed to be together so
that would be a star four whereas if you
see a 100 CDT by itself it would only be
the star 10 the star 10 has reduced
activity whereas the star 4 has um no
anen activity so this becomes a little
bit challenging
um
if if clinicians are not understanding
how uh Laboratories are assigning the
phenotypes a St R 4 star 10 heter
compound heterozy would be seeing one
copy of
1846 and then two copies of the 100 ca
t so it does become somewhat complex in
in understanding what the hpot types
are now um I also wanted to comment
about cytochrome p452 c19 in this case
there are two common variants that
predict Poe function and um very common
in the Asian population uh less common
in in Caucasian or
African-Americans there's other known
variance which also includes a star 17
which is a rapid metabolizer phenotype
so it actually um increases the
expression of the gene this has got some
notoriety recently because of cicil
which is a platelet agregar and it is
considered a prod drug and it's
activated by a number of different um
cytochromes but including cyp2c19
and there have been um a number of
studies shown that failure to respond is
associated with genetic variance in the
cyp2c19
there is always
the challenge
of deciding whether you go with a
genetic assay or a functional assay and
in this case a a platelet um a
functional assay and each of them have
their pros and cons uh but one of the
advantages with the genetic assays is
that you actually could identify it
before a person is is actually put on
the
drug then the one last category I wanted
to talk about is the host genetics and
infectious diseases so there are two
examples um hepatitis C with interferon
and il28b now we all call it
il28b but it really isn't il28b they are
regions um close to it it's the closest
Gene with it uh there is an assumption
that it probably is something within the
il28b but it has not been identified
yet so these variant in the I 28b region
is associated with spontaneous um or
treatment induced recovery from uh hcv
infection
there is also an example for HIV and aav
therapy with the Hib 571 alil so the
hypers sensitivity to aav is strongly
associated with this alil it has a very
high um negative and positive predictive
value so by testing for um HLA b571 you
can reduce the incidence of a hyp
sensitivity reaction and this is
recommend recomended by the FDA for
pretherapy
screening okay now I want to switch a
little bit switch now to our genomic
sequencing essays and in genomic
sequencing we do multi- genes exomes or
genome sequencing each of them have
their advantages and some disadvantages
so with multi- Gene panels we do only
known genes associated with a specific
disorder we also look at intron Exon
boundaries it has a fairly High a very
high depth of coverage but again it's
limited to to just that known set of
genes um with exom sequencing when we
say exom it's not 100% of the exom but
we can get about um up to maybe 95% of
the exone this again will be all known
genes um in the exone and the Inon Exon
boundaries there is an intermediate
depth of coverage between aene panels
genome and when you start analyzing at
an exome level there is a a challenge in
the
interpretation genome sequencing that um
essentially covers all of the exome it
does include genes the inter and int
genic regions as well it has a lower
depth of coverage but coverage but a
very high breadth of
coverage to handle a genom it's first
anal ized similar to an exone and then
if causitive variants or mutations
cannot be identified then we'll go to
doing additional data and
reanalyze so I'm going to start with the
clinical exome or the genome and the
clinical exom is available in clinical
laboratories and one of my colleagues
will be speaking about it this afternoon
um but when we analyze the clinical exom
again we start with genes associated
with disease so do we limit it to um
genes in the online melan inheritance in
man or the human um genome mutation
database well that's where we definitely
need to start with and then when we do
an exome we will find incidental
findings that are not related to the
disease at hand there is a
recommendation from acmg for actionable
and this is where I put in our
pharmacogenetic variants that it also
could be an incident I wanted to also
point out that in the clinical realm we
don't do Gene Discovery really when
we're looking at the clinical Exel that
is in the R&D at the moment but with
that said there is somewhat of a
precedence when we went to Sanger
sequencing all of a sudden even though
we knew the gene was associated with
disease we were doing mutation Discovery
so for a number of years now we've been
doing mutation Discovery in The Clinical
Laboratory so are we um um approaching a
time when we actually could do Gene
Discovery in a clinical
setting uh in analyzing an exom or a
genome we take advantage of filtering
and we can do this because we're looking
for rare variants these uh the diseases
that come to us for exom analysis are
ones that uh they're unable to find the
cause for the disease they are most
likely very rare diseases so we use
symptoms to guide our analysis that
means that we can filter out common
variants so we filter out known benign
variants we use DB snip and the common
Snips or the 1,000 genome or the St 5400
so these are population um basically
population um
sequences and uh what's even more
important is that we use the frequency
data so for example if something is
found in in 20% of the population uh
variant is is at 20% of the population
but the disease is a very rare disease
it's very it's um fairly safe to say
that that variant is not causing the
disease so again as we're looking for
rare variants we will not start with
endogenic regions we'll probably filter
out even deep in chronic regions for
first go around we will look for
variance of Interest meaning
nonsynonymous variants or those known to
um to be
delerious and I will just put a plug in
here that we all need a better clinical
database and ncbi is working on that
with
clinar um and hopefully that'll be a
curated database and clinical
laboratories are um have agreed to be
submitting um
information again we can look at regions
of Interest so even though we do an
entire exomer genome we can really
narrow it down um we can look for Canada
genes or we can look for by chromosome
or we can look by
variant and so now I wanted to talk with
these incidental findings the American
College medical genetics they list 56
genes these are medically significant
and they are actionable in other words
there are treatments available or some
other way that it will alter management
of the
patient and when we are looking for
these uh we need to do a second analysis
specifically for these variants because
we may not find them by our symptom
guided analysis when we're really
focusing on the disease um and the
symptoms in trying to determine which
genes and variants may be
positive so what about the
pharmacogenetic results again these are
germine variants can they be included
similar to an incidental
findings in a sense they are considered
actionable if if a person is going to be
going on medication it may be good to
know this so is this uh something that
we can add to our exom and give
pharmacogenetic results as a secondary
type finding to our exom
findings uh there are discussions such
as what type of inform consent or
approval would we need from the patient
and uh these are being worked out for
the ACM Gast of incidentals um variants
but has not been talked um much in the
pharmacogenetic
setting so using looking at the
pharmacogenetics from The exom genome
here again is my disclaimer of all
limitations and challenges first of all
it's not disease Associated and so we
can't use omum or hgmd to look for genes
with specific symptoms um and since they
are common variants often we can't
filter by population frequency so two of
our best ways of
analyzing um variants for rare diseases
are not available to us for
pharmacogenetics um there are we still
have the challenges of variant outside
the region or intronic on boundaries
that we would need to design around and
repetitive or JC Rich regions are going
to continue to be a as they are with all
genes um so xon one
often um may not be covered very
well
um one of the main problems with doing a
pharmacogenetics is that there are many
of these genes that have pseudogenes
involved with them or what are called
segment segmental
duplications the copy number variants
are not not well UND um not well
technically uh validated yet by Next
Generation sequencing we hope that we
can um
but not necessarily uh we may need to
have some
workarounds again we'll have to have
workarounds for structural variant such
as translocations inversions Gene
conversions now one of the other
challenges from the exom or the genome
is that we need to translate the stars
or the Hypes into RS numbers or to
standard nomenclature and this actually
has been a challenge and I will show you
some of the the challenges we have of
just making sure we're looking in the
right position and then as always there
are some uncharacterized
variants this just shows an example of
the list when I first um you know tried
to pull out some genetic variants from
an exom and we would get a very long
list but sure enough I saw a cyp2d6
variant and not surprising and the
analysis program that we have can give
us a lot of information and it can pull
up the Gene and let us read about the
Gene and um look at some of the the
phenotypes associated with it uh we can
look at our own internal frequency we
can pull out frequencies um from other
places it'll give us an s number and um
and references with it so as we go
through this we can then go variant by
variant and see if it's going to be
something that would be
significant now that is very challenging
doing that with an exome so even though
we have all of that data we may need to
narrow it down so uh when I first look
at it looked at an exome for pharmac
genetics um I could pick out a couple of
cyp2d6 Etc but it was very challenging
going through all the all the variants
that we pick up with an
exom so our next step was to say okay
even though we have an exom we don't
need to analy analyze it as as an exom
let's analyze it
as um as a gene panel and so we chose
the known genes these include the cyps
the salts ugts uh different ones and
identified which genes we wanted to look
at and so now we're not doing a whole
exome even though the data is for the
exom we're now narrowing it down to only
known
genes now again we need to we went back
and looked at all of these genes and
said how many of them are we going to
have problems with because of pseudo
genes or duplications and as we looked
at that there were a number of genes
that are affected such as cyp 2 B6 2d6 3
A4 3 F2 the H there's a lot of variation
within that
region il20 ab and realize that we're
not looking in the
il28b gene we need to go um Custom
Design the regions associated with those
variants um ugt was I thought was very
interesting because ugt 1 A1 1 A3 1 A4
A6 and A9 they all differ only by the
first Exon so it may be a difficult to
to determine which Gene really has the
variant in
it so I took our exone samples and I um
wanted to look at we had 14 different
exms that we looked at and I could not
um filter by Common variant or by Rare
variance so I had to keep the common
variance I could filter by dilus effects
for things that are known um delerious I
could filter by quality scores so to
make sure I'm getting real variants and
not um next genomic sequencing artifacts
but again um I had no disease to
associate it
with and I took just one Gene and we
really need to do this with all of the
genes to look to see what the the
coverage is for this Gene this is DP
dpyd um in involved with 5fu and um as
you can see we get variable coverage uh
throughout the exom and so to really
understand what is covering we need to
get down into the Exel
level on a gene by Gene
basis here is a
summary of these 14x samples with total
variance then single nucleotide variance
um we given a quality number and a
transition transversion ratio uh number
but if you look at all of these um I had
approximately 100 um
to 140 variants per patient that we
would need to look through very
carefully to see if there is anything
there um so when I then filtered and
used some other filters with this I was
able to pick up and narrowed down to 57
variants and so this one example I
wanted to use is that we picked up a
variant in cp4 F2 now first of all we
know that that's one that has a
segmental duplication so we need to have
we need to figure out if we're looking
at the real gene or if the segmental
duplication and it may require a
um handling this separately now it was a
missense
mutation so it wasn't an obvious
pathogenic mutation it had a very low
frequen queny reported in the population
so again I don't know um how to how to
think about it at that level so
obviously not much is known about it it
was a very low depth of coverage and so
I have here and you can see that I've
only picked about maybe six times is
that real even so we would need to sing
or confir sing or sequence it to confirm
even if it is real and then the other
difficulty is that it's not even listed
in the a little nomeclature the database
that um that we use for cyp4 F2 and so
again this would then become an
uncertain variant that we wouldn't know
how to handle
differently then when I looked at the
sample and pulled up it had a lot of HLA
variants with it now we really are only
interested in a couple of um HLA
variants such as the
571 so maybe this is this is when we
started thinking maybe this isn't the
approach to take maybe our approach is
that we need to start analyzing by known
variance so this is
um a chart of the 15 uh different
samples that we used or I'm sorry 14
different samples with the known
variance things we already know how to
interpret and that we can look to see
what their genotype is so if if you can
look around here there are a couple of
um
cyp2c9 variants that we are picking up
since that's a very straightforward Gene
these are most likely real
um we have
some uh further down some
cyp2d6 and it actually says a star 4 um
on line
14 but again we have to handle that very
carefully to make sure that we're
looking at the real Gene and we haven't
determined that yet is how much um
interference are we getting from the Cog
Gene so we really liked this approach
and a potential even with our exome test
is to be able to give a pharmacogenetic
result back not based on the entire
exome not based on even uh 50 known
genes but based on the known genes with
the known variants that we can
interpret so in going on then um genome
sequencing is very expensive exom
sequencing is is also expensive so what
if we wanted just a test for
pharmacogenetics but have a very
comprehensive
test so we've done a gene panel with a
haloplex enrichment and and running an
alumina this does increas increase the
depth of coverage so the problem that we
had with a CF um cyp 4 F2 example
wouldn't
uh we wouldn't have that type of a
problem because we would have a greater
depth of
coverage these would include all of our
single Gene tests and then things that
there are guidelines for and things
recognized um as being clinically
relevant now we recognize that we're not
going to be able to pick up everything
by our Gene panel but this gives us an
opportunity to supplement by PCR so we
can do a long range PCR to actually um
avoid the pseudogene and look only at
the H at the real Gene um we can look
then for translocations or Gene Gene
conversions uh we can do this by long
range PCR this is how we're doing our
cyp2d6 Gene anyway in The Clinical
Laboratory um there's been some initial
work to see if we can simply include it
with our halolex enrichment so that
we're not doing a second um sequencing
run that looks promising um we need to
do more work on
that but the exciting thing about doing
this type of a gene panel is that we can
then package it into Specialties and we
don't need to look even at all of these
50 genes um for every patient so we
could um package it into things such as
pain man management
Psychiatry Cardiology or oncology you
know looking at the termine
variants um this will greatly um help
our interpretation if we do narrow it
down to Simply the genes involved with
pain management but the exciting part
here is is truthfully being able to then
um have a single test in the gene in the
genetics laboratory but being able to
really focus on the clinical issue at
hand such as pain management and
um or one of the other
Specialties now I just wanted to bring
up problematic cyp2d6 again and this is
still um we have to be very cautious as
I mentioned before the pseudogene um 27
dels duplications of functional as well
as nonfunctional LS we may be able to
pick up the duplications of
non-functional Ls by Next Generation
sequence this is an area that I would
would really like to get into the data
more um there are known Gene conversions
that we need to uh to design
specifically for
them the one question about the pseudo
genes is does the alignment include
include it we need to be very cautious
in the interpretation for those genes
that we know have
pseudo but we could um the probes will
hybridize to the pseudogenes but you may
be able to get the greater specificity
by the alignment but we are planning to
fill in by longrange
PCR there's another issue that is
difficult with CIP 2d6 it like others
are using the stel
nomenclatures but the traditional
nomenclature is based on the reference M
3388 and so there are now um and that
actually um one of the reference genes
actually
does not include one of the exons so an
Exxon is deleted in it so if you start
numbering at the first of the gene you
can go to a certain position such as 600
in this um but then after that you need
to add a different number to come up
with the standard nomenclature so we
need to translate all of the stars and
all of the traditional nomenclature into
standard nomenclature that will work
with um the Next Generation sequence
in and again we still won't be doing the
hpot typing um even though there um
maybe some chance in the future that we
could uh do more molecular hpot typing
but again 100 ca t is a star 10 whether
as we have a 100 c t plus the 1846 it
will be the star four so far the
informatics has not been developed for
Next Generation sequencing to take these
into account so we have some informatics
work to do as well
so here is a gene panel variant review
that that I quickly pulled up and tried
to look at at um overall and I did pick
up a cyp2d exp variant um in this case
it was called um 622 Del a well the
other numbering is 775 da a and if you
look at this this does become star three
so my next step is to go and see if this
is real
um and a part part of that is the
validation of this in a for a clinical
setting of taking known
samples that we know the genotype to or
taking these samples and regenotyping
them with our single gene assays or by
saying our
sequencing this just shows the alignment
um and if you can look it in there you
can see approximately half of the reads
have the deletion of this a so the
alignments actually look pretty good
with this um again we need to then
confirm I wanted to use then the cyp2c19
target to show um that there
are ways um just some of the ways we
need to carefully go through Gene by
Gene so we use the integrative genomics
viewer igv to review coverage and that's
actually what I showed you on the
previous
slide we review the full Gene and the
targeted um variants to make sure that
we have coverage um if we want to do the
full Gene we need to have Gene the
coverage of the entire Gene if we only
want the targeted variance we can look
at only that so the table here is our um
attempt to translate the known Stars
into chromosome positions so it has the
RS number as well as the star
nomenclature the standard nomenclature
and C do numbering
and then um the xon its in and then the
chromosome position to look specifically
for it and so we have been working to go
through all of the the known variants
and get them translated into uh
chromosome positions so I wanted to show
you here's our cyp 2c9 in the igv and we
pull up our reference Gene and we can
look specifically within that
region um not only that we can then go
into the um coverage areas that we can
see specifically that variant and look
to see what the coverage is so this is
certainly a way that we can uh need to
very carefully and
cautiously go through the
um each gene each variant and make sure
that we have the coverage and I just
wanted to show you something where we
don't have coverage so um we did attempt
to put in and analyze around other
variants that are not in the coding
region and the star 17 for 2c9 was not
um it's in a five Prime uh reg of the
Gene and when we looked at it um it is
not covered now with that said when we
looked at our il28b regions that we
tried to design specifically for the S
um single
variants and others then yes um we had
designed it we had captured it so this
is an area that we will now need to go
back and revisit to see if we can then
um be able to include the star 17 uh
since that is a clinically important
variant for
us so as I said in the beginning we're
just stepping into this there is a lot
of very complex data by our genome
sequencing but it can be done so our
pharmacogenetics data can be done from
the exomes and from the gene panels it
obviously can be done from genomes as
well but um I didn't have genomes to
work with I worked with the
exomes there are um major biological and
analytical challenges with submental
duplications
translocations and even with simply
changing to a standard
nomenclature I actually um did some
guidelines um for the American College
of medical genetics with CP 2d6
nomenclature and we did put a um an
appendix to that for common variance in
2d6 where we did the translation for you
and then the clinical interpretation
since that is so critical for clinical
laboratories that we do
need to be able to do variants that we
know how to evaluate and so even for our
ex exom we would then focus on either
known on our known PGX genes or um
initially we'll go to our PGX varans and
use the PGX genes then as more of a
research type um project until we can
get a better
understanding and I want to acknowledge
an awfully lot of people who have helped
with this um in our group um in specific
um Dr Mau and Dr bayak toyir have um
Been instrumental in um getting the Next
Generation sequencing in into our
laboratory Dr McMillan is our
pharmacologist that I work closely with
in pharmacogenetics and um Dr melis is
um our research scientist in
pharmacogenetics that has done much of
this work um if not all of this work and
we uh and I appreciate the help that she
is giving us and the understanding we're
getting this is an exciting area and um
very fun project to to look at uh for
clinical laboratories but we do need to
have uh be careful in what we are doing
because this is clinical results that we
are we would be giving and I um want to
then mention the CME code that's
available and that concludes my
presentation and we have a few minutes
for questions and I see some questions
have come in and the first question is
is there any disadvantage in in whole
genome
sequencing um there are advantages and
disadvantages the advantages obviously
are that you're getting the entire
genome and so if you can't find
something in your first analysis you can
then look into the deep andronic regions
or you can look in intergenic
regions some of the disadvantages is
that it's still doesn't give a very um
High depth of coverage so so um we won't
be able to have 100 200 types um reads
um and so we may be getting more false
um false positives or even false
negatives with with a whole genome um
whole genome sequencing oh I'm sorry I
was reading this is whole genome
sequencing this is whole Gene sequencing
let me finish with the whole genome
sequencing and I'll go into
this
um
the
so the other disadvantage for the whole
genome sequencing it is is that it's
still much more expensive than if we do
the gene sequencing um a gene panel or
even an exom and uh one of the reasons
is that we can include more samples at a
time um at our with our uh Gene panels
so that we can really reduce the
costs now um if the question really was
the disadvantage in in the gene
sequencing
um I still think Gene sequencing and
even by singer sequencing is still very
important for genes that you know that
they have the clinical presentation so
for example in um
hemophilia the factor H Gene people are
typically diagnosed with hemophilia by
um factor eight levels and if they are
low levels um or low activity then um
that's the diagnosis now it doesn't make
sense that then for us to sequence the
genome or an exome or even a gene panel
when um we know it's Factor so I would
imagine that in the near future until
costs become extremely competitive that
we will still be doing Factor rate by by
a singer um Gene sequencing and there's
a number of those
examples um we are also using Sanger to
confirm uh variants uh so to make sure
that we're not reporting out false
positives
um the second question is asking about
longrange PCR let me see if I
can with long range PCR do you not fear
to be exposed to PCR e errors with no
ways with no way to recognize them and
then long reads or paired end reads may
be a safer approach to look at
structural variance um that is
true um the PCR error
errors
um
again with our with our pharmacogenetic
ones most of these we have ways to look
at them anyway um we use long range PCR
and we validated them the PCR errors do
exist and I have seen that at time um a
couple of times in in my
experience um
but
typically in repeating
reproducibility uh we really haven't had
that much problem with the errors of the
PCR um long reads is certainly a way to
look at structural variance um paired
end
reads
um it may be a sa it it may be a safer
approach but I'm still not sure that the
reads are long enough to be able to
handle it uh so if we need to do the
entire cyp2d um six Gene to completely
avoid the pseudogene um I'm not sure the
Next Generation long reads are still
going to be able to do
this um I'm I'm not sure I answer that
question or not but I try to and then
the last question is is open access
database like Farm J GK up to dat and
accurate I hope it is I
um I'm really not sure I know that there
are some um some updates and uh or some
professional societies that we rely on
to um try to keep us updated um but
that's one of of the challenges we
always will
have um let's see we still have um
a uh couple more minutes so I just got a
little message
that um paired end reads with 454 will
give you ranges up to 20 kilobases so
that's actually a very good one thank
you for that
information um the other question is
when do you see Labs will be mandated to
report in incidental findings of whole
genome
sequencing
um right now it's just a
guideline uh but given that guideline
given that it's from a professional
Society um I think most Laboratories
will be moving towards doing that um
most most clinical Labs so even though
it may not we may not be mandated that
is I think where the field is going um
most of the times there are very few
mandates that we have unless it gets
into you know potentially a a capap
checklist um where it becomes a
requirement but I haven't seen that
happening whether it's mandated or not I
think the labs will be doing it um there
are still uh questions
and some um disagreements with the
acmg uh basically to say do it on
everybody and not to basically um ensure
that they are um have given a informed
consent for it um there is a question
about whether this is a large enough
panel or should we add more genes Etc to
it um so there are still a lot of
discussions to be had and a lot more
work that will be happening um we have
not started reporting this out in The
Clinical Laboratory but we are doing the
ground work to try to be able to see
what what we can be able to do
and with that I don't see any more
questions and we are about 2 minutes
before the hour so I will thank
everybody oh one more question came in
can I do it in one
minute is it more useful to analyze the
DNA sequence or the amino acid sequence
of a protein structure to determine the
cause of a
disease
um it's it's easier to analyze the DNA
sequence than to determine the amino
acid sequence um it is easier DNA is
more stable than proteins especially if
you need to look at enzymes um but the
bottom line is whatever we do with the
DNA sequence we look to determine what
it does to the protein so it really is
not as much the DNA sequence that is um
that determines well I shouldn't say
that but DNA sequence um can determine
the protein structure uh but we always
remember that what we are doing is
trying to predict what would be
happening to the protein as opposed to a
a DNA sequence okay now that is our time
is up thank you very much for your
attendance um thank you for your
questions I hope I've been able to
answer them um at least somewhat uh for
you and we will uh we will end this
seminar reminds you about the CMA codes
and if you need CMA credit thank you
very
much